>>Aaron: Adopting a flipped
classroom model requires
creating a new culture of
learning and like anything
that disrupts the status quo,
that changes takes some time.
>>Jon: Here are some strategies
to engage key stakeholders,
including students,
administrators and parents.
>>Aaron: So I once had a
student say to me, "Mister Sams,
you just like this
flipped classroom model
because the students are
doing all the work in class."
And I said, "Yes, that's
exactly what I like it.
I want my students to be the
most engaged participants
in the learning process.
I want their minds active."
So if you start hearing from
your students that this is hard
and it's unlike anything
I've ever experienced,
that's a good sign.
That's a sign that they're
engaged and you're transferring
that ownership to the students.
>>Jon: With those students,
if you stick with it,
they will learn to take more
ownership for their learning.
>>Aaron: A lot of teachers
are often surprised
that their administrators
are excited
about flipped classrooms
already.
They've read the articles,
they've seen the emerging
research indicating
that flipped classrooms are
a viable teaching strategy.
>>Jon: But if you
have administrators
who are a little hesitant
about bringing a flipped
classroom model into the school,
then we have a couple of
strategies that you could employ
as you bring them
into the conversation.
>>Aaron: In fact, open and
honest conversation is one
of the great starting points
with your administrators.
Talk to them about how this will
increase the student engagement
in your classroom and be
very communicative about some
of the changes that you'll
be making in your classroom
as you start to adopt this.
>>Jon: Or just simply take
them to a flipped class.
There's nothing like seeing the
flipped classroom in action.
Parents generally love the
flipped classroom model
for two reasons.
Number one, their student
gets more individual attention
from their teacher.
Number two, the parent
doesn't have
to be the content
expert at home anymore.
That role stays with
the teacher.
>>Aaron: However, if you
find yourself in a situation
where some parents are reluctant
to adopt an instructional
model that's different
than the one they grew up with,
you could try teaching them
about a flipped classroom using
a flipped classroom approach.
You could make a video for
your back to school night,
your curriculum night
or your open house,
in which you explain
how the class works
and then the parents could
view that ahead of time
and bring questions to
ask you when they show up.
>>Jon: What better
way to teach parents
about the flipped
classroom model
than to flip the
back to school night?
>>Aaron: So let's recap, your
students will probably love this
but if you're getting
a resistance, remember,
the transferring the
ownership of the learning
to the students is worth it
for them in the long run.
>>Jon: And if your
administrators are hesitant,
take them on a visit so they
can see the flipped classroom
in action.
>>Aaron: And for your parents,
teach them about the flipped
classroom using the flipped
classroom approach.
>>Jon: Remember, transforming a
culture of learning takes time
and support from
everybody involved.